bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors première
question on le sait l'hydroxyte origine
est commercialisé en france en son nom
du père kényan et pour d'autres maladies
que le commis 19 par exemple pour le
lupus ou les rhumatismes
là en ce moment si le professeur didier
rahout saisi la justice et qu'il ya un
problème d'approvisionnement c'est bien
ça oui c'est ce qu'on a cru comprendre
c'est qu'effectivement le laboratoire
sanofi respecte les recommandations
administrative du gouvernement qui sont
quand il n'ya pas de rte dans nombre
d'autorisations de l'utilisation d'une
molécule aura et même de ne pas livrer
les médecins et les pharmacies dans ce
cadre là donc
sanofi et dans la loi dans les règles de
la loi maintenant là on s'étonne un
petit peu c'est effectivement pourquoi
priver le professeur raoul tu de cette
molécule
à ce stade de l'évolution de la pandémie
parce que aujourd'hui on est là au moins
démontré une chose par l'utilisation
qu'il a fait de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
c'est l'absence de toxicité de celle ci
puisqu'il l'a utilisé quand même
massivement lors de tous les essais
qu'il a pu faire enfin des essais des
des traitements thérapeutiques qu'il a
pu faire il ya chez méditerranée donc
c'est un petit peu étonnant de le priver
à ce stade il a de la capacité
d'utiliser cette molécule
non seulement vous il est sûr et certain
que cette molécule est efficace entre le
courant navires us qu'elle s'était
compliqué moi j'ai pas les compétences
pour vous dire si oui ou non cette
molécule mais on peut on peut le
suspecter on peut le supposer il ya
énormément d'études dans le monde y a
pas que la france a toujours l'habitude
de regarder son nombril donc le contre
on vient mais il ya quand même
énormément de pays énormément de
chercheurs dans le monde ya pas que le
professeur raoul qui pensent que cette
molécule est efficace et dans les
professeurs français vous avez quand
même un cercle dont le professeur de
médecine
parmi les plus éminents qui ont cette
même lancée par six mois je m'amuse un
peu parce que je regarde un peu comment
ça se passe dans en médecine comment les
uns et les autres véhicules leurs
messages et donc on entend on entend les
gens qui défendent un petit peu la
théorie du professeur out ou qu'ils
veulent
à tout prix traiter cette épidémie qui
s'exprime et ils le disent de façon très
forte très hautes et très clair le camp
le camp d'en face est relativement si je
peux me permettre cette expression est
relativement silencieux ou en tout cas
agi agit en sous main mais pas
directement
c'est à dire aux jeunes je n'ai pas
connaissance à moins que je me trompe
d'un éminent professeur de médecine
français qu'ils aillent devant les
médias et qui nous disent ils ne
l'étaient interdit de prendre de la
drogue si chloroquine c'est dangereux
ceux qui en prennent vont mourir parce
que il se trouverait que si un tel
propos étaient tenus par un
professionnel de santé et que d'
aventure on découvre dans quelques mois
ou dans quelques semaines ou dans
quelques années que l'hydro le cycle
rockin est efficace les gens qui n'ont
pas bénéficié de ce traitement pourrait
l'accuser d'une perte de chance alors qu
à ce jour on ne peut accuser personne
on ne peut pas accuser en tout cas le
professeur raoul taux de perte de chance
donc moi j'avoue que je pense qu'il faut
le laisser faire pour qu'ils nous
démontrent au cou ou pas ou pas que
cette molécule est efficace peut-être
peut-être ne réussirent à t-on pas à
démontrer qu'elle est efficace mais en
tout cas il a la légitimité à l'utiliser
tout simplement par l'article 5 du code
de déontologie qui dit qu'un médecin ne
peut aliéner son indépendance
professionnelle sous quelque forme que
ce soit donc légitimement médicalement
professionnellement et déontologiquement
le professeur out assume ses décisions
ses choix et ses opinions thérapeutique
alors pourquoi l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament at elle refusé de
délivrer une recommandation temporaire
d'utilisation à la mono qu'une passe
dans l'administratif comme vous n'avez
pas un grand professeur de médecine une
autorité scientifique de haut niveau qui
viennent officiellement nous dire
écoutez c'est dangereux c'est impossible
il faut pas le faire je l'interdît
formellement personne n'a le courage de
le faire de façon personnelle et
verbales à ce niveau de compétence parce
qu'effectivement il risquerait d'être
attaqués par des familles qui
s'estimeraient en perte de chance et ça
les retrouve s'il se retrouvait dans une
situation pénale extrêmement compliqué
et bien comme personne de scientifiques
on ne peut pas lui opposer
raisons scientifiques en sûrs aux des
raisons administratives tout simplement
alors il me semble que vous avez proposé
de tester un lead roxy chloroquine sur
des médecins volontaires porteur d'un
kobe 19
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué c'est
à dire que ça c'est une fonction que
j'occupe en tant que président de la 4c
on a eu
nous avons eu cinq mille trois cents
médecins qui ont été touchés par le
comique 19 que nous avons pris en charge
et que nous avons et nous avons
malheureusement perdu 43 médecins qui
sont décédés du colis de 19 43 43
médecins libéraux qui sont décédés du
col et 19 donc dès le début d'épidémie
de façon à apporter une pierre à
l'édifice
j'avais proposé qu' on puisse se tester
chez des médecins volontaires volontaire
elle est touchée par le col vite 19
d'utiliser de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
sous leur propre responsabilité
étant donné qu'il s'agissait évidemment
d'une population facile à contrôler et
qui disposait des compétences pour
assurer un autocontrôle de cette
molécule
et je n'ai jamais reçu de réponse je
n'ai jamais reçu de réponse ni favorable
ni défavorable
on n'a pas donné suite aux demandes que
j'avais fait donc évidemment c'était une
n'a pas pu avoir lieu merci thierry
allard donnant en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
j'appelle votre médecin généraliste et
membre du collectif né sont les presque
remercie